[Musik]
[Applaus]
was ist das für den job zu suchen oder
ein computer machen ich habe meine
station nicht einfacher wollte aber
shopping-clubs sie musste der un chef
vor der tat aus wie sie das ist
natürlich der beste job katastrophe
der cheftrainer ist eine flüge
nationalmannschaft daniels lee alias
tiger zero ist seit 25 jahren mit leib
und seele patrice nächstes jahr sollen
seine tiger flugzeuge ausgemustert
werden und daniels lee geht in pension
doch jetzt will er es nochmals allen
zeigen mit einer neuen show fürs
fünfzigste jubiläumsjahr
was braucht es alles um ein solches
programm zu entwickeln
davon handelt dieser film
[Musik]
am heimatflughafen emmen diskutieren
tiger sie rotieren und heike sexy das
neue programm
es existiert erst auf dem papier ich
hatte echt gespannt was er da musst
einfach die jugend und versorgung seiner
form und haben dann könnten die mich
reizt der job mache
die lupe nehmen gleich alles wieder okay
und sogar minus ziehen würde stärker
wachsen ok den heimatort time around
nicht gesetzt haben so muss ich mir
kommt sagte ballacks damit da nur drei
quattro und expert das habe ich auch
getan hat natürliche die figur die er
regelmäßig dabei sind und da als andere
kleine tagesprogramm sowieso nicht also
der mechanik wechselt ab 50 euro
ganz speziell auch maskottchen flat eric
wartet auf die geistesblitze der drei
cracks wo liegen die schwierigkeiten
figur der hand für sich sind gleich mit
schwierigkeit schwierigkeit liegt
zwischen figuren dass es auch
tatsächlich und das opera meter stehen
möglichkeit für den erst figur dass es
zwischen ihnen aber nie aufgehört weil
wir uns auch etwas probieren und da ist
den bereichen flug ob es funktioniert
oder nicht und ob schuster vom boden aus
dafür ist daniels lee zuständig sein
ziel heute die staaten für eine
bergkette im kanton luzern das
praktische training der patrouille
suisse hat begonnen
das neue programm wird zuerst hoch oben
über den bergen ein gilt bevor es die
knoten dann in bodennähe fliegen
[Musik]
richtig schön wie immer ist horsley
guten mutes denn so toll schaut das
wetter nicht aus neben hörste steht der
interne videofilme der die figuren zur
analyse aufnehmen soll
aber wo sind die tiger da die piloten
das programm noch nicht gut beherrschen
halten sie einen weiten abstand zum berg
wie beurteilt daniels lee das neue
programm wenn er nichts gesehen hat
der woche hat der natur spielern aus das
gesamte programm mit allen abläufen
wechsel und auflösung machen da noch mal
ein teil von formationen also das von
kurt morgen gesehen und dann das in wels
und treppe müssten richtig beurteilen
also der daniel hösli
der zweig optimisch vom dienst nein nein
ich denke dass das training sich für sie
meine flexible themen wenn diese
metapher ist natürlich der
grundlagenforschung und darum ist es
wichtig dass das machen können oder
spielen ob die figuren funktionieren
bleibt offen
in emmen ist bereits eine neue
werbebroschüre eingetroffen
auch ein jubiläumsbuch ist unterwegs die
pr maschine läuft
selbst die seriöse das abgelehnt ja das
einmal mit einmal das kommt natürlich
und marketing und verteilen die werdet
unterschrieben aber keinen eindruck doch
das macht frei das gehört zum
aber es ist nicht nur alles show sondern
auch harte arbeit die einzelnen figuren
muss jeder pilot im schlaf beherrschen
sie werden runter gebetet wie ein mantra
in der luft geht es rasend schnell mit
tempo 500 bis 1000
doch jetzt gibt es drei mal rauch
vor dem gebäude in emmen steht der turbo
porter der partie swiss mit ihnen begibt
sich horsley zum nächsten einsatz mit
ball 57 jahren darf hösli in der armee
keine jets mir fliegen aber mit dem
turbo porter ist er immer noch in seinem
element
[Musik]
daniels lee ist mit 5300 flugstunden ein
sehr erfahrener pilot offensichtlich
fühlt er sich nirgendwo so wohl wie am
steuerknüppel eines flugzeugs es regnet
noch aber laut medien soll es demnächst
aufhellen
barneys ziel ist bellers ein kleiner
segelflugplatz zwischen murten und
bielersee einige fans warten bereits
sie wissen dass die patrice bis heute
hier trainieren wird sie alle kennen
dann und dani weiß auch wie wichtig der
kontakt zu den fans ist dennoch steht
die abstimmung über das neue krippen
kampfflugzeug bevor
aber wenn wir nicht eine abstimmung aus
je geboten etwas investieren und das ist
besser als ein panzer paraden und
promotion und ausflug im tritt mit 800
stundenkilometer sind das ist gut so
nein
[Musik]
der militärflieger jargon heißen seine
piloten bambini und auch dani würde am
liebsten mit ihnen durch die luft
fliegen
[Musik]
leuchtkugeln sogenannte flyers sind teil
des neuen programms
sie dienen sonst dazu angreifen die
raketen abzulenken
[Musik]
wo also soll ich zwischen das seit
dieser vorher stoppen
[Musik]
präsentiert
das finale grande ist der abschluss der
show
[Musik]
wir sind das volk
der erfolgstrainer auf dem weg zur
arbeit
schon sein großvater war flugpionier
sein vater segelflieger und einer seiner
drei söhne ebenfalls gelohnt
ranis büro liegt in judendorf dort wo
die fliege reihen der schweiz ihren
anfang nahm
das war einst die abfertigungshalle der
swissair heute sitz des berufs flieger
kurs der luftwaffe fliegen ein
traumberuf
weiter verzeichnet das ich happy mit dem
profil die flügel wie viel klüger selber
naturwunder gesellschaft man im team
faszination sich dreidimensional bewegt
er sich also vom weinstock russland ist
theorie macht miteinander sport also
vielschichtigkeit findet man schnitt
also dass die sechs flüge der buche
gegend um die zeit ohne einsatz und ja
aber deutlich später soll jeder pilot
muss 120 bis 150 stunden später auf dem
check das ist fortschritt der
trainingsflüge dafür der partei badghis
also sprich führt armee um für flüge und
darum dass aus dem ganzjahres besser
geht s nicht mehr pushen nicht mehr
umweltbelastung selbst für den coolen
danny gibt es heiße tage
heute startet die patrouille suisse um
das neue programm dem waffen chef
vorzuführen
die figur male beobachtet von
korpskommandant also schellenberg
als erste partner gefunden
und einmal mehr der tunnel im neuen dem
alten programm ein markenzeichen
wie immer folgt die videoauswertung der
geflogenen figuren stets wird analysiert
und verbessert mitspielt macht sich zum
programm vorherige präsenz vor dem
publikum nicht wenig erwartet wie
subjektiv der chef ist zufrieden nun
folgt am nächsten tag der auftritt vor
dem fanclub der patrice erzählt über
3500 mitglieder
sie kommen auch bei schlechtem wetter um
das neue programm zu bestaunen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die piloten mit ihren farbigen tiger f 5
flugzeugen haben hier den status von
popstars
derzeit bestehen darauf dass ford
übernehmen
wir haben wir jetzt
ja nie weiß wie man sich in der
öffentlichkeit verkauft er ist
mittlerweile pr profi geworden
showbusiness will gepflegt sein bei jung
und alt
daniels lied das bad in der menge
vermissen wenn er zurücktritt öfter mal
lachen schweiz das erste training der
patres nach dem volks nein zum krieg
ihre tiger flugzeuge sollen ausgemustert
werden
die einzigen verbleibenden jets sind
dann die f a 18
niemand weiß ob es da noch genügend
kapazität für die showtruppe geben wird
die fans sind besorgt die emotionen
schlagen hoch rang ab
mit dem krieg bin ich beruflich ist er
nun ein stummer haben sie ist eine
wohnung
das ist längst über sie behauptet
schweiz vertreibt die hand schweiz
verbreitet der ganze wald und das am
rhein sind korrekt so bedanken sie waren
toll schließlich ist das blöd
schlachthof jahren abgeschafft und damit
nur kein übermut sponsoren speedo das
braucht einfach trainingseinheit der für
diese militärpiloten präzision überblick
und es finden hier will die opposition
rief gar nicht
tätig und weiß eine dauer sichere spruch
von den teilen ab stimmig und hat
zurzeit einziger österreicher gestorben
hat er sich besonders skype und
schlussendlich wenn wir jetzt mit dieser
situation fertig werden das hat noch
viel vor allem bedeutet für sicherheit
in der schweiz für luft polizei die
luftverteidigung und tourismusmanager
wenn man das organisiert dass man mit
einer weniger flüge trafen die zukunft
der partei suisse ist ungewiss dennoch
ist sie nach england zum höhepunkt der
saison angereist
erfurt ein flieger jahrmarkt der
superlative mit einer aufwendigen show
präsentiert von italienern briten
franzosen und vielen anderen
die schweizer piloten und mechaniker
staunen
[Musik]
im gegensatz zur patrice bestehen die
meisten anderen show formationen aus
vollprofis die nichts anderes fliegen
als vorführung
und wie geht es da nie ums leben
hi aber ich freue mich sehr
[Musik]
über 200 flüge sind dauernd 2 330
zuschauer
[Musik]
und dann sind sie dran
unsere top guns die bambini von daniel
hösli so flieger im nebenberuf
jetzt wird sich zeigen ob sich das
wochenlange training gelohnt hat
[Musik]
perfekt
und wie immer das finale grande als
abschluss
eine verwechslung der herzig
ich habe perfekt die forscherin es
brauchte schon immer besser machen alles
gestohlen
doppelsieger formationen sind perfekt
wir sind happy
nach der gelungenen show spricht
luftwaffenchef also schellenberg
persönlich zu den piloten und mechaniker
die sind begeistert
die zehn tore unterschied zu so zu einer
der akteure france und die genauigkeit
und dorfen deswegen video performance
mache ich einfach darum gestellt und so
motivierten danke sage sondern zurück
was aber allen unter den nägeln brennt
wie geht es weiter mit der patrice der
waffen chef hat vertrauliche
informationen dafür fehlen was geschäft
sein
was passiert jetzt mit patrice wies der
gurt die botschaft brauchte ist zeit
dass die armeeführung besucher zum
departements chef politiker der patrice
festhalten und mir dann immer zeitig auf
den dicken flüge diese eher
unwahrscheinlich habe dass mir auf drei
fahrzeuge und wechsler
das hat er mir bestätigt das ist also
der villa vor der obersten führung und
das stimmt uns optimistisch
heike zero der ewige optimist mit
zusatztanks beladen fliegen seine tiger
weg von verfolgt noch ein jahr lang
werden sie mit daniels lee und dem neuen
programm auftreten
dann wird ein neuer chef gefordert sein
[Musik]
die hitze ist schluss sind sowieso nicht
funktioniert er hoffe dass ein anderer
dann mit dämonen verfolgt mit sich
nehmen
vertrauen sie der spur zum kanadischen
ständig neue forderungen
[Musik]